all right i'm going to get started thank
you all i'm opening the interim study
committee
meeting on house bill 1229
which i have affectionately dubbed the s
interim study on whether or not we
should have a study
that's the way that it's written but i
want to clarify for those of you that
are
watching and with us
i'm representative sue mullen from
bedford i chair this interim study
with me to my right is representative
art ellison
and to my left representative oliver
ford two members of the interim study
committee as well
so when we were looking at
uh the group of
school meal or nutrition related
standards bills that we heard
this past session
um
the question became you know
would one of those bills be a vehicle
for further study so
while it may look like this interim
study is merely about whether or not we
should study this
it actually is the umbrella that we're
going to be looking at a variety of
bills
under
those bills are house bill 1229 which is
the interim study bill
house bill 1561
house bill 1564
house bill
1657 and house bill 1660 which uh i know
you gentlemen have information on that
if anybody else wants to
look at those bills as we address them
then you're free to
grab one of these
these packets
also in the audience today is
representative timothy horrigan who is
the prime sponsor of
1229 and also tim of
our representative horgan of 1660 which
was the breakfast bill would you like to
come up and just say a couple of words
about school meals and
sort of what the impetus has been for
the bills that you have proposed
[Music]
when i first got about thinking about
this relatively
recently one wise
i've always thought
i've always thought that more students
should be getting uh
all students should be fed at school and
if you do it for free that's fine even
the relatively affluent families um
i don't have a problem
problem with that and i especially got
thinking of it during the pandemic when
in my school district and
i think probably
just about every other one
they uh instituted a free lunch for
everybody because the they were going
around the school buses were going
around everybody's house and delivering
it was easier for various reasons to
deliver the lunches
to everyone along with the instructional
materials for
several reasons one of which was simply
that uh
in the interest of confidentialities
otherwise the kids would notice like
which houses were getting if you limited
to just the free reduced uh the free
lunch kids the other kids would um
definitely notice like who's getting the
lunch and who isn't so you know they're
very smart about that very clever about
that sort of thing you know so um
and i also want to make sure the uh
school breakfast was uh was it was
expanded and so i've been um
hacking
i've been like
working in that issue for uh for several
years without uh with i guess a certain
amount of success but we haven't like
actually passed anything and um
and then other other groups of
representatives have similar ideas in
there too so that was uh i'm not sure
what else more there is no i think it's
uh i i think your efforts have been
admirable because i think you've kept
the issue alive in the eyes of many of
us from uh year to year
and i
i think all of us in looking at these
bills are
pleased with the bipartisanship that
is present on most of them that these uh
you know hungry kids are hungry kids
period
so i i certainly have admired your
efforts on this and uh
is there um
well let me let me let me just go
through the process of introducing what
we're going to do
today next week and then maybe uh if you
have further information you want to
share with us we'd be happy to have have
you come up then
so thank you
all right so 1229 as i mentioned is the
study committee bill
and as an interim study you know what
we're going to be doing is looking at
whether or not we are recommending or
not recommending future legislation so
we'll put that aside
at this point and maybe at a future date
decide whether or not we actually need
the study committee or if we're able to
study
the issue without the study committee
1561 if we go in chronological order is
a school nutrition standards bill
we are going to have the department of
education
food and nutrition services with us next
week at our meeting
so
i think that
getting their input and reflection on
what was being proposed
by uh house bill 1561 would probably be
a good idea
and perhaps representative deschez will
be able to be with us then also
15 house bill 1564 is a breakfast build
that too
came before us
and along the same lines as
representative oregon 1660 it looks to
address
food insecurity and meal needs uh in the
morning
in addition to
just offering the required meal at noon
time
so we'll get some information about that
the
1657 which was the farm to school
reimbursement program
those folks have been contacted and they
have asked
to
meet with us in september as opposed to
now
so that they can pull some additional
information together for us
so unless anybody has an objection to
waiting until september then i think
we'll do that
and 1660 is
as i mentioned representative horgan's
breakfast bill so perhaps representative
horrigan and representative duchess will
be working on one
potential for uh the next session
if you're both re-elected right if not
then we will pass that baton on to
whoever is successful and
wants to make sure that we don't have
school children that go hungry
i also
have a couple of points of information
for us uh i have an outline of
topics that we're going to be talking
about today
if representative ellison if i could get
you to hand this to representative hall
all right uh
an article came out
yesterday i believe in
a publication called k-12 dive
that
indicates that you the usda is about to
invest 100 million dollars in school
meal programs that are innovative
so i think uh once
we
get to the farm to school initiative we
might
be looking at that as well
and also
excitingly today we have two people from
the new hampshire hunger solutions
project with us we have laura milliken
who's the executive director and jessica
goran who's the deputy director and if
you would like to come forward and
sit at that microphone then we would be
happy to hear what you have to share
with us today
[Music]
good morning
uh i'm laura millikin um laura can i get
you to you're gonna unfortunately you're
gonna have to swivel this thing to be
heard sure i thought we could sort of
share but
um
so uh we have a packet of materials that
we'd love to give out great
so as laura's handing that out i'm
jessica goran i'm the deputy director of
new hampshire hunger solutions
and we're here today to
you know talk to you about the the bills
that were presented this year but as
well as maybe look at some opportunities
for
for next year
um
in all of the information you'll see new
hampshire does really poorly in school
breakfast participation we're 47th in
the nation
um
and what that means is that we miss
about 7 800 kids a day
feeding them school breakfast
and we all know that when you have
breakfast you can learn better
the letters go home to
uh families the day before any big
standardized testing reminding famous so
that they can do really well on those
tests
but we know if we feed children every
day they'll do better in school every
day and do better on those tests every
day um so not only do we miss feeding 7
800 children a day but because of that
we leave about 1.5 million
federal dollars on the table that would
go to
um
school nutrition departments they are
separately funded they are not funded by
the school budget they have their own
budget and so
when they have increased participation
they have increased income
and those federal dollars can help to
support things like farm to school when
those those dollars come in so any
policies that we can put in place that
will help to improve school breakfast
participation
will
help with those dollars help with
feeding more children and also help with
better
health outcomes and reducing food
insecurity in the long run
does anyone have any questions for uh
representative ellison
thank you for taking my question um
in terms of the the 47 percent
nationally
obviously that's a that's a statewide
average
is there information available
for the municipality by municipality
school district by school district that
gives us specific numbers that make up
the 47
so we are 47th out of 50 states right um
so
it's our it's our ranking
but yes we do break it down by percent
by school district
when we get those numbers from the
department of education
um but just to kind of give you an
example we work really closely with the
nashua school district
and
um
there are certain policies that can
happen within a school district like
breakfast offering breakfast after the
bell which increases school
breakfast participation
um
of the five title one elementary schools
in nashua four have implemented
breakfast after the bell during the
pandemic when school meals were free and
they are feeding about eighty percent of
their students when they have about 72
percent free and reduced eligibility the
one school who is not offering breakfast
after the bell that is a title one
school with about 70 percent free and
reduced eligibility is only serving 26
of their students
okay
so that's the kind of thing that would
be very helpful for us and we do
you have access to it you can get it to
us the department of ed can get it to us
uh
not only school district by school
district but school by school which is
what you've just done which is what
that's information that would be very
helpful to us or to me yeah we're happy
to do that
i have a question for you laura if um
so
you mentioned the nashua school district
in particular how many school districts
are you interfacing with
at this point
currently just manchester and nashua on
a regular basis okay
and my my own follow-up is uh is that
because
other school districts aren't aware of
what you're doing is it because of a
lack of funding is
both of those things all of the above
yeah okay
and if i may jump in we're certainly
looking to expand our capacity to help
all school districts who want to uh do
better in their breakfast participation
um
i have
if i may be so bold i have two
suggestions for um for
focus areas that i suggest
so
one is there's an opportunity to to do
what's called medicaid direct
certification
you may remember that there was an uh an
amendment to a non-germane bill
i think it was 1620 hb 1627
that asked the department of education
the department of health and human
services to participate in a medicaid
direct certification demonstration
project that the usda had available
that would allow the matching of data
between kids who are eligible for
medicaid and
at the right income levels for free and
reduced meals would be directly
certified
um and we um
estimate that there would be a huge
impact um for hungry kids in the state
yes that actually came before us right
at the end of the session
i know that there was
some
concern about
client privacy i believe it was the
privacy of the data that was the red
flag
that
prevented
certain members from
from feeling comfortable signing on so
we have a
in your packet the third
handout is all about medicaid direct
certification
and certainly there were concerns
expressed about privacy
i think that some of the testimony
was somewhat misinformed
there is no sharing of of data parent
especially parent data with the federal
government that's just that is not what
happens
there would be there would be data
sharing between dhhs and doe
but they are already sharing data to
directly certify children on snap
for free and reduced meals so they there
is a track record of them doing it uh in
a way that is respectful of of data and
at no time is parent level data shared
we're only talking about child level
data
um
can i'm sorry
can i add to that real quick i just i
have been working really closely with
manchester nashua as i said and i spent
some time with their free and reduced
eligibility administrators their free
and reduced eligibility administrators
are the only ones in the school district
that have any access to the student data
when it comes in and it's only to um
identify them as free or reduced
eligible
and then it is all coded electronically
so when that student comes with their id
um they swipe their id and their meal is
taken care of right there's no
additional
identification that that child would be
free or reduced and so and every student
pays for their meal that way so it
doesn't identify those students in any
way at all
and that one person is the only person
that has access to the data they're so
careful with it that if they know that
social services in their school district
is working with a family that is free
and reduced eligible
they cannot reach out to that social
services teacher and ask for them to
help fill out that form
because um
because the data is so protected
um
so i'm happy to answer more questions
about medicaid direct certification if
that's um the other thing that i sort of
wanted to throw out there is that summer
meals is a real issue um
and you know is uh similarly
administered although some
some summer meal sites are not schools
they are community based
um
it seems to me to be an extension of
school meals
it's sort of what do we do when
children are not in school
and are hungry
so
i
respectfully suggest representative
ellison and
following up on that are the
reimbursement rates for for summer meals
however they're being delivered the same
as they are during the school year are
they different
well it's a bit of a complicated
question because it depends on where you
are and you're on the community's level
of poverty
um so
um
so there
can you answer that more clearly and
there's two summer feeding programs one
for um areas that
are not eligible to feed all children 0
to 18 and that's this
summer feeding program and then there's
a seamless summer option and seymour
seamless summer option is what the
school districts are using right now to
feed all kids year round and that's at a
higher reimbursement because it's based
on higher poverty rates
and that's where the medicaid direct
certification that laura is talking
about would also be beneficial because
when more students are identified
as being eligible it increases that area
eligibility and it would increase the
communities in new hampshire that can
offer free summer meals for all
thank you
just to add one more thing
sorry to keep switching back and forth
but
there is a genuine crisis that's about
to happen um countrywide but certainly
in new hampshire as the
uh the waivers that have allowed schools
and summer meal programs to feed all
children will end at the end of june
unless congress acts
so
but if those waivers end
you know we have already been contacted
by a number of summer meals programs
that are not going to be able to do the
the level of service that they did last
year or not going to be able to offer
summer meals at all
and school districts
will
have a very very difficult time you know
figuring out how to feed as many kids as
as they did before most of them will
only be able to serve children who are
eligible for free and reduced meals
at those respective costs um and
and that will
no doubt create hunger
um for children
uh yeah i've uh so
does your organization have uh
any access to
what implementing a breakfast program
for instance we have a couple of bills
that were that are specifically looking
at breakfast programs
we heard
some facts and figures during the
lap during this session
that
it was estimated that maybe 30 schools
were not providing breakfast
and that maybe one of the reasons they
weren't providing breakfast was because
they could not
absorb the startup costs for a breakfast
program
does new hampshire
hunger solutions have any data
at all on what those startup costs
might be per student or
do you have anecdotal information about
places where
it was thought to be impossible and yet
here it is and it's working
effectively
we don't have that data on hand at this
moment in time but as a part of this you
know committee we could get we could
gather that data i would say that it's
um probably the majority of it is a
staffing issue and funds for staffing
because those staff members would have
to come in at an earlier hour so it's
the initial
it would be the initial labor hours that
are needed in order to start up a
breakfast program
um and
in food purchasing but
i know that
that gets reimbursed and the commodity
foods that come into the school
districts can cover that initially so
um in my opinion it would be labor hours
initially but laura has something else
oh i was just going to say that i think
that the best people to ask that
question to is the do
or at the doe i mean i think that um
that uh they've probably
well there's not
so much turnover there but i think that
um
uh
there are people probably who have um
shepherded people through so
um
our own board chair uh
uh ran the nutrition uh
programs at the doe and we could
certainly uh talk to her about how um
sherry white
oh no before sherry i'll be fortunate
okay all right i'm like
sherry white now retired go and do this
oh sherry retired
all right no i'm sure sherry would know
yes yes
yeah thank you as i mentioned um we have
them scheduled to come in and meet with
us next week
um but you folks were so on top of
things and so enthusiastic about coming
in today it
was bring it on down absolutely if you
have information for us
share it
i i think what we'll
what i see us doing during this meeting
and then piggybacking on the doe is
maybe coming up with a list of questions
that we would like answered and
certainly
on this committee
we look at
cost
and i know that
whether it was the structure of the
bills themselves or
i i don't have the answer for why it
seemed so difficult to estimate
what exactly things would cost
but um
you know representative horgan's bill i
i think was somewhere around six hundred
and fifty thousand dollars and
representative de shea's bill it was
determined that they couldn't estimate a
cost so uh
anything you can do to sort of give us
uh
any thriving indicators that you have
would be greatly helpful for us as a
committee
representative allison uh just another
question to to tie down numbers here
that bill that we dealt with with the 30
school districts that didn't have
breakfast and
that was a struggle uh
just on that alone
but
you're talking here about
7 869 students without school breakfast
it seems to me that goes beyond 30
school districts then doesn't it yes
yeah those are the um students that we
so i'll start with the formula there's
food research and action center provides
a formula to measure school breakfast
participation um so they look at for
every 100 students that are free and
reduced eligible participating in lunch
that there would be 70 free and reduced
eligible students participating in
breakfast in each school okay so that's
where that that measurement of and the 7
100 um that number comes from frack
so um that's only for school districts
that are participating in the school
breakfast program that would it would be
additional to include the 30 school
districts that do not have a school
breakfast program
so we're we're talking about in the 78
69 we're talking about school districts
that offer a breakfast program but not
everyone who is eligible for the
breakfast program is participating and
that's the
that's the difference is am i correct
and
yeah saying that yeah okay thank you
any questions representative ford or
representative hall any additional
questions
anything that you folks would
any additional things to share
well certainly work to answer the
questions you've raised um although i
think we'll need help from the doa for
much of it right um
and um and we look forward to addressing
this we um
you know uh have been
trying to increase our capacity
to address this issue um and and to
assist schools
in expanding their breakfast
participation by changing the way they
offer breakfast
this is a challenging time for schools
and we're really well aware of that
right both because of supply chain
issues
with food and because of staffing issues
so
i you know i mean i want to be very
clear that we are
very cautious about asking schools to do
more without adequate support right you
have to have an infrastructure and
for the building to stand representative
ford you have a question
thank you madam chair
i have a
sort of an untechnical question if you
will it's more of an attitudinal
question but you probably experienced it
so i'm going to ask you
without reference to any particular
school
but one of the comments we heard when we
were talking about this
though several months ago
was that if the school system wanted to
have breakfast and they should decide to
have breakfast and there was kind of a
they choose not to kind of
propose our statement and
not i mean the last school lunch i ate
was in 1957 so i don't claim any
expertise in this at all
um
but it was just sort of
is it just a question of the um
shall we say wealth of the town the
budget kinds of sensitivity that they
might choose not to have breakfast for
children an occasion quite a flurry in
our committee about people who would say
how can you tell that these kids come to
school hungry
well then the people who had been
teachers and principals spoke up and
said they don't perform very well
and so i was just sort of looking for
your read when you see it
what do you sense is is the kind of
i guess knee-jerk reaction when you say
we need to have more food in the schools
or more breakfast or something like that
if you feel free to comment on that i
would appreciate it thank you
you know and you don't have to bag
anybody in particular it can be a broad
general statement
i think laura and i probably both have
different stories to share and things
that we can add so i'll start with just
um
i know in
schools that we've worked with and
talked to that
school nurses have 25 visit 25 hunger
related visits a day per school in the
district
um that's kids going to the nurse's
office because they have a headache a
stomach ache they're feeling tired um a
variety of reasons and then the nurse
codes that because they're that that
student was um
their
symptoms were alleviated by being by
having a snack or given a breakfast um
because they weren't able to have
breakfast when they left the house or
maybe they left the house at six a.m and
by nine they're really hungry again
right um
so when a school district does not offer
breakfast at all there's not even that
other opportunity so i think that the
you know when we start asking these
questions we have to look deeper right
and asking the school nurse like how
many visits are they seeing how much
money is the school nurse spending out
of their own pocket to provide snacks
how much money is the are the teachers
spending out of their own money
to provide snacks or um some schools
even have pantry programs how much money
are they spending out of their pantry
project in order to offer snacks in the
morning when the school breakfast is no
longer available um whether it's because
there's a breakfast isn't offered after
the bell or
breakfast is not offered by that school
at all um and i think that in general
people have been really surprised when
they hear the percent of students that
are having hunger hunger-related visits
but that might not even have had dinner
the night before so the only meal
they're getting a day is school lunch if
they participate in that
thank you
and one thing that i would add is that i
think that
schools often are very busy being
schools and educating students and
aren't as focused on their school meal
programs i think that despite the fact
that there are quite a number of studies
now that show the benefits of breakfast
to students not just in the short term
but really
in the long term and i've included a
couple of uh of articles um
with the
study sources uh cited
so despite the fact that there is all
this great research that shows how
important breakfast is i think it's not
well understood i think people i think
that often schools think well we offer
breakfast
you know not realizing that the
breakfast participation because kids
have to come in early and sort of be
tagged as those kids
so often kids don't participate as they
get older because they don't want to be
stigmatized so i i think there's a lot
of education to do i guess this
is the takeaway i think that
um
that schools
need to better understand and they need
the support to to make changes
i i have a question for you um do you
have a sense of uh
i mean manchester and nashua are similar
in the sense that they're both cities
but
different certainly in
makeup and
population
do you have a sense of
what the percentage of
you know total population of students
what the percentage of kids
who would benefit from
a program like this is and how the
districts are covering the cost for it
i mean is it 50 of the students is it 75
percent of the students or does it vary
from neighborhood to
neighborhood so it'll vary from school
to school um and then by school district
and
um and then by community in new
hampshire right so it is it's a little
bit of it's
um it can be complicated math but the
doe does a great job of breaking down
all of the percents of free and reduced
applications that are of eligibility by
community so what we do at new hampshire
hunger solutions is when we're working
with the community we look at on percent
poverty
and then we look at on percent poverty
by census tract and and look at it with
um free and reduced eligibility for
example manchester has about 46 percent
overall free and reduced eligibility
but there are schools in their district
that have eighty percent so when we're
looking at that census tract or that
school district um we would look at the
census tracts
that attend that school
to measure that so
um
for the 30 schools that don't have a
breakfast program we would have to have
a list of those schools and then we
could then
go and look at their free and reduced
eligibility and see the percent of
students that would be impacted by
having a breakfast program
and then base it on
lunch participation so
it's that
percent of free and reduced eligible
students participating in lunch we're
looking for 70 of them to participate in
breakfast
thank you for that and my the second
part of my question was how are they
managing this in terms of
resources i mean you mentioned
staffing
obviously if you're going to serve
breakfast you have to have at least a
few people in in the morning to sort of
get things up and rolling so the
districts would be um
on the hook for that
uh what about what
or would they the districts the the
school district budget is separate from
the school food service budget
which in a lot of communities in new
hampshire um they actually source that
out to other programs like cafe services
um and i'm losing the other ones but
there's a couple other in the state that
off that that provide the programs and
it's because they're funded separately
so um their funds come from the
reimbursement from school meals
so
i apologize for not having these numbers
off the top of my head but like this was
supposed to be an organizational meeting
we're gonna we'll be meeting again okay
good so uh school breakfast is about two
dollars and sixty cents reimbursement
for a um
free a student who is eligible for for
uh for free breakfast so of that 2.61
or 60 cents per student um that meal
reimbursement pays for the cost of the
meal and pays for the labor hours
and anything any other overhead that's
associated with serving that one meal
per student so
um so again it's numbers the more
students that participate and
by protect providing breakfast after the
bowel you get more students to
participate um then they'll have more
money to
fund a breakfast program there may be
some there definitely are startup costs
um involved and again like laura said
the doe would know more about that but
as far as once it's up and running um
those are the types of that's how those
programs are funded
representative paul
thank you
thank you for taking my question sorry
are there
any kids who are left out because
parents aren't
willing to do the paperwork to
and how is that
handled so
you know how if they're not willing to
say hey i need help
i'm too proud
you know what about like cause i have a
feeling that might be
super
population out there yeah and that is
when the school district is impacted
when a parent doesn't fill out the form
that that
is presented to
the school district
to reimburse that debt so
if a child is eligible but not
identified as eligible because the form
is not completed and they're not
directly certified through snap tanf or
foster care
then um
then they just keep tap
receiving a bill
every time they participate in school
lunch and depending on the school
district and it's not a great thing to
say but
um some kids will then only be allowed a
sun butter sandwich
some kids will
be denied and they'll say you have
a little announcement will go off at the
register that says you have a high
balance
um and you can't receive your lunch and
we've also heard stories and these are
stories so i can't and i don't know um
which school districts but these are
stories um that food service staff have
thrown away the lunch when the student
gets there and they have too high of a
balance to receive the meal
i'm not surprised thank you
representative ellison
uh
following up on that uh if the waivers
go away are we back to
then
which parents fill out the forms and
which ones don't i mean back which is
the situation we had for years anyway is
that correct that is correct so that was
kind of the disappointment of um the
medicaid direct certification bill not
passing this year
um we're still trying to the
application's not due until september so
if we can figure out a way to get the
approval
for doe and dhhs to fill that form out
um
then we would
in the 2023-2024
school year would use medicaid direct
certification as the eligibility
measurement versus
having to fill out the form
and do the waivers are they going to at
this point without further congressional
action
going away this june or next year this
june 30th this month yeah thank you
and i'll just you know not to go down
a rabbit hole but i'll just flag for the
committee that
um that the
the way that we measure poverty in new
hampshire turns on free and reduced
meals um so
uh you know it is significant that there
are a number of parents you know who who
can't or won't or are afraid to fill out
free and reduced meal forms
um you know not not just in the school
meal space but in a whole range of
uh education
funding
for schools
um
additional questions
all right feel free to stay in touch
with us
and uh
obviously you're welcome to attend any
meetings that we have scheduled we will
be as i said meeting next week then we
will be on recess for july and august
so we will be uh back in in
september uh with the you know
understanding
my heart goes out to you in terms of
that application that's due in september
because it certainly is not this interim
study committee that has the authority
to
approve that application process but
uh
thank you so very much for bringing your
information forward and any additional
information that you would like us to
have feel free to come back
thank you so much for the opportunity
so
in a
similar vein i will say that
the new hampshire education network
nhen on monday june 13th is doing a
webinar on food security and changes in
programming for new hampshire students
and families
jessica i believe is
the primary
speaker perhaps in that jessica is that
safe to say
yeah
christina pretorius from reaching higher
is also involved
if you
do you happen to have the registration
posted on your website i'm sure new ham
reaching higher in new hampshire has it
posted on theirs but
the public is invited any uh
elected officials are invited but you
need to go to reaching hire's website
and register
for the zoom link to be able to
to watch this and that's monday june
13th
from four o'clock to five o'clock
i've already registered so we're
we're good to go that came across my
screen last night
so i'm interested in input from the
three of you about
any
topics that you would we have the doe
coming next week so
uh
i would like if you have specific
questions that you would like the doe to
address
if you get those questions to me
within the next couple of days then i
will
package them and make sure that kelly
rambo and
melissa white are
aware i would like to streamline the
process if we can if i can if we can
give them questions ahead of time
then we may actually have them appearing
before us next week with some answers
rather than
developing the questions
if not then at least we know
they'll know uh what
july and august will mean in terms of
what kinds of things we're looking for
so it makes sense
i was going to yell at you
you should
uh in terms of uh
your perception of where we go we're
we're looking then
obviously
at the fall in a series of meetings and
coming to some conclusions i would
suspect before
those of you who those of us who may or
be re-elected or coming back in january
that we would have a package we would
have a recommendation for the committee
prior to
january 1st with that is that a fair
assumption uh yes
yes
certainly by
the report i believe is due at the end
of october so we have to have our
interim study report in and
what we will be doing is saying either
yes we recommend future legislation or
no we don't recommend future legislation
that legislation does not necessarily
need to have been written by then
but certainly
incumbent legislators
can start with ols i believe the first
week in september
so i would think
because i'm looking at representative
horrigan who's nodding up and down our
school meals cheerleader that um
any any member of this committee or any
other member of the general court who is
running for reelection can certainly
draft legislation based on what we hear
as a part of the centrum study
uh on their own and then the committee
will need to decide whether or not you
know it's a
straight up yes we think that this needs
additional legislation or uh
no we don't for whatever reasons
yeah does that make any sense
okay
uh and and
additionally regardless of what we
recommend legislation may go forward on
this topic i would anticipate that it
would i uh you know the this
we're a study committee
so we're low on the totem pole
um i would think that there will in fact
be people who will
on either side of the issue ultimately
go forward
yeah thank you
oh
madam chair yes sir representative ford
get where i can be heard um
are we going to
consider schools that are uh
charter schools and things like that in
addition to
the
traditional public schools yeah i would
think that we when the department of
education
is with us
one of the things that i would think
that we would want to be looking at are
school meals period yeah you know
regardless of where those school meals
because i i'm curious i want to know
because we have some private schools in
new hampshire that participate in the
school meals program we have public
schools in new hampshire that don't
participate in this so i'm i i would
really like the doe to use this
opportunity to
educate us on the variety of scenarios
that are out there
because i you know as i've said
you you've heard me say that ad nauseam
right a hungry child is a hungry child
no matter where they live or where they
attend school and we need to be looking
at all of them i think i uh
when i first got put on this committee
began asking because this is outside my
realm of experience
since i was a child i've had no
experience with this business except for
running a kitchen when i was in college
but
the whole funding and and the issue of
call it shaming or whatever it might be
of people who had to admit they couldn't
afford to feed their children breakfast
is
entirely new to me so i began asking
around and i stumbled upon a lady who
was
running
a collective of
70 or 80 homeschooling people our home
type school things and she has already
conducted a survey
and given me 80 something responses
to questions about meals and so forth
and of course we can
change the questions and send them back
out and so forth but
what i was basically saying i'm sure
each of you has those same kinds of
conducts contacts and that we might want
to reach out and and find out you know
just more because for me it's a
discovery process from day one i mean i
i i admit uh
my knowledge is very slender on this and
so
yes i think it it needs to be i think
the question is how much of it needs
legislative address how much needs some
other form of address or even just full
public conversation
about that as an issue
and uh you know i quite agree that that
this is something that we certainly
ought to be able to get to a point where
we can say this something needs to be
done we're not sure what but
you know this needs to be addressed and
considered yeah i don't um
i really
homeschooled students i think may fall
under a different category than
federally funded public school programs
charter schools or public schools in new
hampshire so that's that they're already
in the bucket in terms of they may have
different rules and regulations but in
terms of the eligibility is being
considered as a public school right the
charter schools won't be uh won't be uh
there was some discussion in the
committee earlier when later people were
asking questions they're legitimate
questions should they be required to
meet the same standards when they have a
lunch
compared to that and so all right that's
a question that needs to be answered
absolutely yeah and and i i don't have
an opinion i'm sure they haven't i
haven't read any of the responses i've
gotten yet i just got them last night
last night but i think that these are
things that we might explore just
because we don't know the answer you bet
yeah yep um i i hear your representative
for it and uh i'm game for the
discussion what
yep yeah yep
representative hall
the starting point is clearly we need to
acknowledge that there is a problem
right i mean
that's the bottom line that we have a
problem that needs to be solved
i'm not sure that everybody agrees
substantially put representative paul
yeah
in terms of whether or not we have the
responsibility to feed hungry children
well i think we
i'm saying start with the idea the
notion that we do have hungry children
yeah that was a question i was asking
you is that what you're saying oh yeah
yeah
that will certainly produce a discussion
as i said representative ford i'm game
for the discussion
thinking of that kid that comes over and
eats all the stuff in your fridge with
you and your kids and them
are sitting there having snacks after
cooling
yourself wait did we buy strawberries
yeah well i'm
i feel fairly confident that
the refrigerator in in the in the school
building probably has a lock on it so
nobody's coming in after practice and uh
and eating out of that refrigerator but
uh you know i do think that we have to
acknowledge whether or not we
whether we like it or not we have to
acknowledge that there are hungry kids
and that it's through no fault of their
own
so
what do we what do we do you know food
insecurity is is
a quasi disability you know
food insecurity affects
how you approach the day that you're in
and if it's chronic food insecurity i
mean i'm sure that we could
sit here and listen to
thousands of stories of
siblings taking care of younger children
of teachers taking care of students of
neighbors taking you know
um because we have populations that not
only live in poverty but we have
homeless pop populations we have
populations of kids whose parents are
incarcerated
we uh
so
this is i i want to i i want to to the
best of our ability i want to focus on
the child
not on whether or not the mother or the
father or grandparent or whatever is not
doing what they're supposed to do
i think what we need to focus on is the
fact that we have hungry kids in the
state of new hampshire
and every morning i pick up the
newspaper and there's another million
dollars in surplus being touted on the
front page of the paper and i'm thinking
holy toledo you know we almost had a
stroke when we saw 650 000 to feed
hungry kids
to feed all kids basically breakfast in
schools so
representative hall
thank you madam chair and to follow up
with your comment before yes i think it
is our responsibility
to um
make sure that their kids are fed if not
us who
if not now when
uh so
again if you have specific information
that you would like from the doe
and you can email me those questions
within the next 48 hours that would be
terrific because then that would at
least give them a couple of days to
the sooner the better
to gather data
and get into us on monday as the first
meeting
between us and the department of
education
does anybody else have anything else
that they would like to raise at this
point
all right true to my word one hour
thank you all for coming i appreciate it
and
our next meeting is monday june 13th at
1 o'clock
all right i am
closing the meeting thank you very much
you